you are in a film that comes out i
believe it's August fourth spare change
august four okay 2015 feature film
comedy spare change I have a small role
in it but I also produced it which was
my first feature film I produced digital
series and been in pre-production on a
couple TV show pitches for larger
studios but never a feature before so we
shot actually the beginning of 2014
independent feature and you know we had
four guys doing the job of a hundred
really and it was an awesome experience
and it's finally come around and here we
are August fourth on iTunes August 4
2015 video-on-demand digital download
itunes google play and amazon everyone's
really really excited we actually just
released the trailer today you know
worldwide internet so it's getting a lot
of use a lot of traction everyone's
tweeting and gramin that's lingo for
instagram booking a facebook as well so
it's really really exciting but being on
the back end of it the producer side of
it it's been an awesome experience from
DeLand especially with the
post-production like during the physical
production that I've always had a grasp
on I've been in those situations but
dealing in the post-production world
especially the post post production when
it comes to the distribution and giving
the rights and and coming up with the
best business plan for your casts and
your crew and for future work there's a
there's a balance there's there's that
you know a lot of films aren't being
released in theaters anymore because
they can get less views on video on
demand but in the long run it makes more
money for everybody that's involved so
it's kind of that toss-up between what
you're going for and it's really really
interesting and it was really exciting
it's there's a lot of content out there
and people are always willing to watch
something or or see what somethings
about there's always a need for you know
it's the YouTube generation that we live
in now so there's always something
people want to watch and we're really
hoping this moves feature film comedy
female centered let me get a little plot
oh yeah please do okay stories about
this girl mid-20s named Jane and a
couple years after college you know
she's your typical mid-20s girl sorry
not the
anything wrong with that but she doesn't
take anything too serious in life she
ends up getting fired from her job and
she finds out her old boyfriend who was
away at the Peace Corps is now back in
town after breaking up with her a few
years back so her life's just in turmoil
and everything's the worst and she
doesn't really know what's going on and
they're like she can't get a new job
she's down on her luck and then she
unfortunately someone mistakes her for
being homeless so that's what she
decides her new job is gonna be and it's
this whole moral dilemma she knows
everything she's doing is wrong she
befriends a girl around her age that
just so happens to be actually homeless
so it starts messing with her head and
her boyfriend comes back into town who
is now working as a Peace Corps now he's
working for a non-profit that
specifically helps the homeless so it's
just this whole back-and-forth and
throwing her best friend Lilly who's
helping her through it all they're
coming up with it and using it as a
business plan to make money and they're
not thinking of it on the personal level
of like she's getting ten dollars on the
street but it could be taken away from
an actual homeless person getting ten
dollars on the street so it's that fun
little balance of playing the realism of
it but living in a movie world at the
same time and it's just a fine
independent comedy it's great we've got
some great people involved in it from
all over the comedy world pulled in
favors we have you know Jim o'heir
alison becker both on Parks and Rec Ross
Marquand walking dead Jordan black
community huge improv comedian when my
favorites out here is the best Elise
levac who also sorry about that when I
said your name at least but I just spit
at least levack who actually won Best
Supporting Actress at the Hollywood real
Independent Film Festival this year
plays our supporting lily and then Lissa
laureate plays Jane Doran who was
phenomenal in her first big feature
acting role she's actually in the music
world and then the male lead was played
by Curt mega who was one of the Warblers
on Glee and then George Lucas as well
she's just actually came over this was
her first role in America she was on
soap opera in Australia for many many
years as a teenager she grew up over
there show called neighbors so this was
her first American role and then Neil
Grayson who's been on a bunch of
different shows on sci-fi channel Krista
Allen's in it Madeline sweeten who would
play a little Allie Barone on everybody
dreamin I make a guest appearance don't
worry about me grant Cotter an upcoming
stand-up whose hilarious and Jackie long
he's been in a ton of great stuff like
the comebacks real house the real
husbands of Hollywood real-life
Hollywood husbands however you want to
put that we just had some awesome people
that were just willing to come in and do
this movie with us and that was just the
cast the crew was phenomenal and and
everyone's kept in touch and everyone's
real excited for the fourth because it's
been so long it's like one of those
things that's oh yeah we put all this
work into this thing a couple years ago
now it finally gets done for other
people to see it well you screen the
film was at februari 14 februari 14th at
the Hollywood real independent film
festival at the Regal Cinemas down at LA
live so it was very very exciting we
sold out like I said we won one award
and we were up for best picture as well
we did not come away with that but to be
part of that festival which was
fantastic they had some you know a-list
actors and actresses and there's some of
these films like Gary Cole Joe montaigne
they want a couple of awards for their
films and to be a part of that you know
meet other filmmakers kind of going
through what we went through it was
really really cool and to have people
say oh a complete stranger not a family
or a friend for the first time something
that no one had any prior knowledge
about to be like that was good like oh
yeah thanks so since you met people that
were going through what you all were
going through did you talk to them about
getting a distribution deal once you
know like the big nights over great now
now what happens yeah cuz it's a little
bit different because you know everyone
knows about Sundance and you know
there's these big film festivals we you
know we didn't we just went to this one
for our worldwide premiere and we
understood our niche you know we weren't
going to try to do 15 festivals and try
to like get someone to possibly purchase
the executive producer chris hughes who
handles the business access business
aspect of this excuse me he's very very
knowledgeable and was up on like the
digital media before anyone he works
kind of in the dot-com world if that's
still a term so he was he had a business
plan for this before was like we're
gonna hit one festival and then
going to get distribution because
there's no point in waiting we
understood what the product we had and
where it could benefit and where where
we could flourish with it and where
everyone that was involved with the
benefit more from it because you know
you hear these great stories like all
this movie was picked up and then it's
released three years later because it's
a big production company and that's
awesome it doesn't happen to every film
at every independent film festival so we
just took you know played the cards we
were dealt and went about it the right
way that's why we're really pumped about
the fourth so with Chris and your other
team you decided that just one festival
and and then straight to VOD after that
that that was it that was our goal you
know and there's different routes you
can take in the distribution world we we
talked with a lot of distributors you
know to put it in DVDs to do a you know
a European release before an American
release there's a lot there's you know
endless different doorways to open up
but like I said Chris who was the kind
of the brains behind the business kind
of brains was the brains behind the
business side he had a very specific
plan and wanted to do it this way I mean
this is film one of our you know our
little production company the two
directors Jonathan Talbert and Arturo
Guzman come from the TV world they both
produced on oranges new black and weeds
United States Tara all these great shows
so just learning from them and that's
kind of how we because TV films quicker
than film does so that's kind of how we
ran everything to stay in budget and to
get things done quick but also efficient
we ran it like a TV show you know
shooting up to you know 10 11 pages a
day sometimes on the weekends and going
late and learning from those guys was
great and using their connections as
well we've had you know a couple Emmy
winners behind the Shannon Mitchell
helped who won an Emmy for orange is the
new black did our editing John Kincaid
who did our sound supervision he's also
works on all game of thrones new girl
orange like name drop all over the place
here but I was learned more from sitting
them with these people for eight hours
and I would have in a classroom for over
six months is really great
you